Медсестра Малі Міхаелі та її команда майже цілодобово проводять вакцинацію у Бат-Ямі,
місті на південь від Тель-Авіва. Тут використовують препарат BioNTech/Pfizer.
Щодня по всій країні вакцинують близько 150 000 людей.
Я справді вірю в цю вакцину. Я також її отримала, і цього тижня отримаю другу дозу.
Ми не мали, слава Богу, жодних алергічних реакцій.
Це як вакцина проти грипу, це дуже м'яка вакцина, і це добре.
Це - культурний центр, який перетворили на пункт вакцинації.
Вакцинацію з 19 грудня 2020 року проводять в усіх лікарнях, клініках та спеціально створених мобільних центрах.
Успіхи у кампанії з вакцинації пояснюють кількома чинниками:
відносно невеликий розмір країни, наявність вакцини й сучасна цифрова система охорони здоров'я.
Кожен громадянин в Ізраїлі має медичну страховку в одній із чотирьох недержавних лікарняних кас.
Пріоритетом було щеплення людей, старших 60 років, медпрацівників та людей з хронічними захворюваннями.
Тепер дійшла черга до 50-річних.
Чудово. Я навіть не відчув уколу.
Я працюю у сфері догляду людей з особливими потребами. Ми на передовій. І тому я мушу бути прищепленою.
Зробити щеплення подекуди вдається і молодшим людям.
Вони готові годинами чекати в черзі у сподіванні отримати надлишкову дозу,
якщо хтось не з'явиться на заплановану вакцинацію.
Адже вже розморожену вакцину необхідно використати упродовж обмеженого часу.
Своєчасне придбання урядом Ізраїлю вакцини BioNTech/Pfizer сприяло швидкій кампанії імунізації.
Стимулювати громадян до щеплень мають і "зелені паспорти імунітету".
Прем'єр Біньямін Нетаньяху зробив гучну заяву. Мовляв, Ізраїль стане "першою країною в світі, яка переможе коронавірус".
Однак нині рівень інфікування настільки високий, що уряд вкотре посилив вже третій режим локдауну.
З одного боку, потрібно провести вакцинацію та виграти час, аби вакцини почали діяти.
З іншого боку, в нас у Ізраїлі вже "третя хвиля" і у лікарнях величезна кількість важкохворих.
Рамалла на Західному березі річки Йордан. Центр тестувань на COVID-19.
Рівень зараження тут також залишається високим,
але п'ятьом мільйонам мешканців Палестинських територій доведеться зачекати з отриманням своїх вакцин.
На окуповані території Ізраїль вакцину не постачав.
За це він отримав порцію критики від правозахисних організацій.
Тим часом палестинська адміністрація, що має у розпорядженні обмежені фінансові можливості,
шукає альтернативні шляхи отримання вакцини.
Серед варіантів розглядають російську вакцину Sputnik V та британсько-шведську вакцину від AstraZeneca.
Міністерство охорони здоров'я підписало угоду про імпорт вакцин з чотирма компаніями.
Партії надійдуть протягом найближчих двох місяців.
Ми почнемо вакцинувати медичні бригади, літніх людей, пацієнтів,
поки не прищепимо 70 відсотків жителів Західного берега, Сектору Гази та Єрусалима.
Хоча населення й вітає очікуване прибуття вакцини, також присутні і певний скепсис та побоювання.
Ми хочемо, щоб усі в нас отримали її, аби не було психологічного тиску. Тому що ми весь час у стані стурбованості.
Але вони хочуть привезти російську вакцину, а ми не довіряємо вакцині російського виробництва.
У новинах кажуть, мовляв, це ще не схвалено. Ми не знаємо, що буде.
Але врешті-решт ми сподіваємось, що отримаємо правильну вакцину.
Бо ця криза охопила всі сфери життя в країні.
Палестинці також очікують препаратів для щеплення від міжнародної програми Covax.
Її мета – допомогти біднішим країнам здобути справедливу частку вакцини -
для близько 20 відсотків їхнього населення.
Поставки вакцини за цією програмою, в тому числі й в Україні, планують розпочати у лютому.
Тим часом у Всесвітній організації охорони здоров'я
висловили критику, що досі 95 відсотків усіх щеплень проходять у лише десяти країнах.
Це, зокрема, Ізраїль, Німеччина, США, Італія, Іспанія, Великобританія, Китай та Росія.
ВООЗ б'є на сполох і закликає забезпечити більш рівні умови доступу до вакцин.